françois tu lis vos n'indique que se
passe-t-il gazinet bon c'est un scandale
un véritable scandale
enfin de quoi parles-tu pour tenez lisez
vous même
c'est peut être ça les fraises des bois
vont augmenter de 4 rôle qu'il joue
c'est vrai c'est un véritable scandale
il ne s'agit pas des fraises des bois
arabe où les vacances de noël risque
d'être réduite de trois jeunes ans je me
moque bien des des vacances de noël vous
êtes aveugle on veut tous les enfants ne
sont sûrement pas de ton avis non mais
regardez là à ahola page 3 ah oui voila
voila voila j'ai trouvé une interview
exclusive de président de la fête de
l'île aux anciennes intérim monsieur des
snobs ça peut être amusant
tu trouves écouter taisez vous et
laissez mali à ce moment je me tais mais
c'est difficile
bon de notre envoyé spécial onésime
farfelu fare potee mérite bien son nom
celui là bas ce son article qui est
partout lui coûte que gémir nous ne
serons jamais s'il n'y aurait pas de
parler mon jean mottet je me fais j'ai
eu la chance de ramener rigueur une
autre vue et goûte avec monsieur fulbert
du snob président de la fête de l'île
aux enfants mais tu parles il est il est
tous les jours sur le port adp pour voir
s'il ne débarque pas un journaliste
alors tais-toi casimir abboche continue
monsieur du snob a bien voulu
m'expliquer ce qui se passe vraiment
dans l'île aux enfants
beaucoup de gens m'a déclaré monsieur
les chinois pensent que quasiment tout
le gros monstre être niais qui vit dans
notre île est aimé des enfants mia tu as
le niais nous avons trop niais pour toi
dire que ça n'est pas très gentille
civile tenait un celui là en vérité
c'est toujours le cedus nôtre qui parle
je suis la véritable idole de lille
grâce à mes qualités multiples à mon
intelligence et un a distancia on peut
dire je crois que sans moi
l'îlot z'enfants n'existerait pas on ne
le trouvait pas après ça on a envie de
lui casser la tête harrison le fait est
que cet article donne pas une pension
très réelle de l'île aux enfants sera
quasiment je comprends ta colère là pour
toi cher ami je cours toujours un
scandale un véritable scandale a
mentionné m
venez sans doute vous expliquer sur cet
article non je n'ai pas encore lu mais
c'est dans ce journal t4 le scandale
tonne n'est encore au deuxième page
tiens tiens tiens une entrevue avec
monsieur casimir de l'île aux enfants
voilà qui promet d'être passionnant et
les déclarations de casimir le casimir
us met en lumière ce qui se passe dans
l'îlot enfin monsieur 10 noble compte
pour du beurre
vous vous rendez compte pour du beurre
ça c'est vraiment la chose la plus drôle
que j'ai dit je continue sur l'île aux
enfants poursuit casimir tous les
enfants disent que c'est moi le plus
beau
gentilly le plus sportif le plus
intelligent en un mot le plus tout
effectivement il ne reste pas grand
chose pour les autres scandaleux n'est
ce pas monsieur du snob
pas plus que vous déclaration à monsieur
onésime farfelues et la vérité nous a
semblé aussi des formes et dans votre
article que dans celui de casino
d'ailleurs j'ai une idée nous allons
faire un concours entre vous deux
comme ça on saura quel est le meilleur
en we love le concours du plus gros
mangeur de gloubiboulga au ne voyons
casimir c'est pas juste le concours il
sait très bien que monsieur dsna
d'horreur du gloubiboulga merci à toi je
suis content qu'on puisse et constater
combien cet individu a un tempérament de
tricheurs notons à part je vous propose
une petite poudre le petit bois ah oui
ah oui vous trouvez ça 13 monsieur du
snob
ce serait très bien que la taille de
casimir l' empêche de passer à travers
les arbres du petit bois
mais oui c'est une honte d'être un
tricheur pareil ça vous n'avez rien à
vous reprocher l'analyse
je crois que nous pourrions faire des
concours quand on sait que j'ai dit oui
à concours de musique
ces concours de musique moi je crains un
peu pour nous aurait ya alors un
concours de peinture se serait pas une
mauvaise idée ça mais c'est avec leur
goût pour la peinture abstraite après ce
serait très difficile de les départager
mais non parce que nous allons leur
imposer un sujet avec lequel ils
pourront faire preuve de leur talent et
de leur connaissance vous avez machin
mais ce n'est pas la peine de vous
donner tant de mal
oui parce qu'un finalement monsieur
listenable et moi on ne s'entend pas si
mal mais c'est vrai ici s'il vous plaît
bien qu a pas parlé de scandale tous les
deux d'ailleurs j'ai trouvé vous
monsieur du snob
vous allez faire un paysage de régions
chaudes tropicales et toi kazimi paysage
de région froide colère
[Musique]
[Rires]
et voilà c'est un beau tableau ah oui ça
je dois dire que tous les deux ils sont
très jolies mais enfin il me semble
qu'il ya pas mal d'erreurs mais aussi
ses erreurs
je ne fais rien les enfants de nous
aider vous avez longtemps mais des
connaissances en venez venez chez nous
casimir et monsieur du snob ont besoin
de vous abandonner
venez tous allés mathias des fables
venez nous aider il paraît que j'ai fait
des erreurs casimir à peu un paysage
polaire ph froid et monsieur 10 noble
lui a peint un paysage de régions
chaudes les comme vous le voyez ils ont
fait pas mal d'erreurs
j'aimais bien les aider en mettant et
vous si chez vous ça m'étonne
alors voyons le paysage de monsieur de
ce noble qui est un paysage de régions
chaudes
il y à un esquimau un igloo un lion un
homme habillé d'un pagne qui court avec
une lance et un pingouin et moi j'ai un
ours à cactus une case à traîneau et à
pamiers
alors vous allez madické une erreur
barbara le cactus
bon alors on va commencer à mettre le
cactus
voilà quelques désirs dans la région
chaude chez monsieur du snob
ah bon ça y est on partage aux eskimos
l'esquimau à ton avis ne vit pas dans
une région chaude
donc on va le mettre dans le paysage
peint par kasimi est là il sera beaucoup
mieux cacher vous cherchez bien
maintenant c'est elle qui catherine
georges l'ours gens croient l'ours il
est dans une région froide il est bien
là tu sais bon alors quoi on attribue
les erreurs que je n'ai pas fait la case
très bien stéphane effectivement la case
chez toi france merci je vais la nôtre
ici ça sera pas mal ensuite joséphine
nigloo ne va pas dans un pays chaud très
bien longtemps c'est bien beau de
l'igloo l'erreur et cubain des signes on
va le caïman lyon on le met sur la
banquise où est alors pour moi se
trompent-ils à pamiers très bien le
palmier ça aussi casimir tout ça devient
dangereux
la jolie peau je crois qu'il reste
encore une erreur
le pingouin là de l'autre côté
oui tu as raison vous me donnez votre
pingouin bien voilà alors ya encore des
erreurs nous eh bien non je crois que
cette fois non vont très bien dans
l'ordi qui a gagné le concours via
casimir j'ai compté trois erreurs pour
chacun trois erreurs pour monsieur du
snob et trois erreurs pour casimir
vous êtes donc ex-aequo ex-aequo avec 0
[Musique]
moi
à
[Musique]